a présenté l'intégration des immigrés
dans la société française
ce préambule étant posées elles sont
faites et nous propose des propositions
concrètes et patrick exemple la création
d'une commission de recours en cas de
refus de non renouvellement du titre de
séjour
nous connaissions d'un recours sur le
modèle des conditions d'expulsion et la
naturalisation la création d'une agence
nationale chargée d'informer le statut
juridique doit être le statisticien
proposé la création de la fonction
policière nombre de bavures ces
dernières années il me semble que les
autorités de l'action policière qui sera
chargée d'enquêter sur ces bavures et de
faire respecter le code de déontologie
de la police et ainsi de faire en sorte
que les relations entre la police et les
citoyens soient des relations conformes
à l'esprit du droit
de l'expression actuelle les réclames
des moyennes tout en suggérant des
solutions l'association a remis
aujourd'hui ses propositions au
gouvernement et aux parlementaires un
portable